Speaker 1: I am going to show you now the
epitome of what was it in Orwell's 84.
It's like Newspeak or doublethink, where everything
is reversed, everything is opposite, night
is day, up is down, etc..
It is undeniable that the alleged shooter's
alleged manifesto from Buffalo supports these
ideas perpetuated almost exclusively.
I mean, just to be to be conservative, 99.8%
by right wingers.
There's no denying that.
That's the rhetoric that was in the manifesto.
So Ben Shapiro's approach, because, listen,
everything's coming off the walls for these
people.
Tucker was saying that there was nothing political
about the manifesto at all.
Ben Shapiro's approach is okay, just claim
that it's left wing stuff.
Claim that the great replacement theory that
we have to worry about non-whites changing
the makeup of the country and changing who
we are and destroying Ben SHAPIRO just goes.
This is a left wing ideology.
He says that great replacement theory contains
an essentialism about race that to him looks
like left wing wokeism.
It's it's it's the Trump thing of don't believe
what you're seeing.
Don't believe what you're reading.
Just listen to me.
Instead, check this out.
Speaker 2: Now the left is trying to do is
broaden out the term great replacement theory
to include any sort of normal concerns about
illegal immigration.
Any suggestions that demographic voting patterns
make a difference, which of course, everybody,
both left and right, knows that they do.
I mean, the left has been claiming for literally
as long as I've been alive the changing demographic
patterns in the United States.
We're going to shift the politics of the country
in a progressive direction.
There's a base of right to share as the emerging
Democratic majority in 2003.
Speaker 1: So now what he's doing there is
kind of slick.
We've talked about for a really long time
that over a period of decades, demographics
shift in a natural way.
One of the things that we've observed in that
shift is that certain states, in particular
Southern states, are becoming slightly more
what we sometimes call Latino or Hispanic
and slightly less white.
And we've all said that will have an effect
on elections that is not even remotely equivalent
to what the right does, which is say we have
brown people, hyper breeding, they're just
pumping out children.
And it's a Democratic strategy to bring illegal
aliens to the country so that then eventually
they will be naturalized.
And as this conspiracy, that's what the right
has been saying.
That's the right idea.
On the left.
And really it's not the left.
It's just in reality we go, Oh yeah, demographics
shift over time and here's how they're shifting
there.
There's no conspiracy to start, you know,
breeding Hispanic women.
I mean, it's dystopian what they talk about.
And Ben SHAPIRO wants you to believe that
it's kind of the same thing, like, you know,
great replacement theory.
Liberals recognize demographic changes.
It's all the same.
No, it's not.
Speaker 2: If you want to talk about the great
replacement theory and what this person actually
thought, you have to actually read the manifesto,
right?
You have to know what the great replacement
theory is.
The replacement theory is the theory that
essentially there is they're a bunch of Jewish
elites.
And this coterie of Jewish elites wish to
perverts, wishes to pervert the racial stock
of a country like United States, a predominantly
white country, in order to weaken the country
from within.
That is the great replacement theory.
It is not concerns about illegal immigration.
It is not concerns about cultural assimilation.
It is.
Speaker 1: Of course, that's very dishonest
because the mechanism that those who are purveyors
of the great replacement theory say Democrats
are using is the bringing in of legal and
illegal immigrants.
I mean, it's he wants to separate the two
things.
Crazy anti-Semitic idea about Jews trying
to change the demographics has nothing to
do with the immigration piece.
Actually, no.
The immigration piece is the tool they claim
is being used to effect the change.
It you can't disaggregate the.
Speaker 2: Two in theory is the idea.
There can never be cultural assimilation.
The great replacement theory is the idea that
racism and that race is destiny.
In fact, the racial essentialism of great
replacement theory looks a lot more like wokeism
than it does like mainstream conservatism
or mainstream liberalism.
Speaker 1: There it is, guys.
The great replacement theory, despite everybody
espousing it, being a right winger is actually
left wing.
It's now some people fall for this.
Now, just as a reminder, it's all right wingers
promoting this stuff.
Here's Tucker Carlson saying that immigration
makes the country dirtier and poorer.
These are right wingers.
Okay.
Speaker 2: Good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight.
Here's a funny thing that we noticed the other
day.
People debate all the time about mass immigration.
What you never hear anybody do is make the
economic case for mass immigration.
But as an economic matter, this is insane,
it's indefensible.
So nobody even tries to defend it.
Instead, our leaders demand that you shut
up and accept this.
We have a moral obligation to admit the world's
poor.
They tell us, even if it makes our own country
poorer and dirtier and more divided.
Speaker 1: Dirtier, poorer and more divided,
and then more.
Tucker, I mean, the stuff is straight from
right wing media.
Speaker 2: I'm laughing because this is one
of about ten stories that I know you've covered
where the government shows preference to people
who have shown absolutely contempt for our
customs, our laws, our system itself, and
they're being treated better than American
citizens.
Now, I know that the left and all the little
gatekeepers on Twitter become literally hysterical
if you use the term replacement, if you suggest
that the Democratic Party is trying to replace
the current electorate, the voters now casting
ballots with new people, more obedient voters
from the third world.
Speaker 1: Now, as you can see, it's not just
some vague thing, it's this is the strategy
of the Democrats.
That's the claim that's being made.
Just a couple more.
I know I played these yesterday, but they
really should be attached here.
So you can see how absurd what Ben SHAPIRO
is saying is.
Here's Charlie Kirk, another right winger.
Speaker 2: President Joe Biden's Department
of Defense will accept 30,000 Afghan refugees
in the military installations following the
collapse of Kabul.
But.
Political transformation.
Let the country crumble.
Do you know there's 5 million displaced people
in Afghanistan now?
This was all intentional.
Joe Biden let it fall apart to now say, oh,
I'm so sorry.
I guarantee you, Joe Biden's speech this afternoon
will talk about refugee assistance and relocation
support.
Speaker 1: So there it is.
This is something the right says Democrats
are doing.
It is not wokeism.
And lastly, Lauren Boebert, same thing.
Speaker 3: Yes, there is definitely a replacement
theory that's going on right now.
We are killing American jobs and bringing
in illegal aliens from all over the world
to replace them if Americans will not comply
with the tyrannical orders that are coming
down from the White House.
Speaker 1: So the ideal thing would be to
say that there is nothing in the manifesto
that is about great replacement theory.
Obviously, they can't do that here.
So the new move is, oh, that's a left wing
great replacement theory is actually a form
of wokeism.
They are just lying to you and many of their
followers are falling for it.
Make sure you're on my mailing list.
You can sign up at David Pakman dot com.
That will notify you on Monday Memorial Day
about our one day membership special.
I would love for you to join on that day.
Just get on my mailing list at David Pakman
dot com.
We'll take a quick break and be right back